all right he's the cover his latest book
is hey mom stories for my mother but you
can read them too there's new comedy
special big underwear is on Amazon who
is the emmy-winning star of baskets take
a look I don't want to look bad on TV
you all I'm a rodeo owner no you believe
it
Christine why don't you just go out and
buy something new honey
I've already tried everything on at the
Dress Barn I'm in between sizes well
please welcome my old friend
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
do not want Trump messing with Amazon
until my book is off the bestseller
Donald please
well Lily it's been such an
argumentative show it has been I've been
good the peace with her Aldo cuz I love
that you stuck to your guns and I love
that you still are you still like
Geraldo you know why I like his Roseanne
I love Rehan and congratulations
Roseanne you can say that you know
people got chipped my friends never
silver my gut said for congratulating
Rose it's ridiculous that we can't even
see and Roseanne is crazy yes but that's
beside the point
beside the point exactly crazy in their
families sometimes it's you yes oh no I
mean you know I get it
so happy to be here I miss you I haven't
seen you in so long
we know each other a very very long
early early days of the comedy store
when we were gonna write that it was a
sitcom or something yes we do brothers
or buddies or we did we've tried to
write a sitcom together once you were
gonna be a conservative no sorry but
look congratulations on every I mean
you're always working that's right and
you do so many different things you know
you're a game show host and now you've
got this brilliant Emmy winning
performance and that is your mother
you're doing yeah or as Ella Anderson
okay I mean she's kind of hero because
she she helped to step in between you
and your bad father right bad father
yeah yeah you know drunken you know so I
forgive him but drunken and you know
eleven children and she stood between
him and our Sandra she saved us I mean
she deflected and and protected and and
then also fed us which really was you
know why I'm so fat is because well I
wasn't going to mention it well it's the
elephant in the room
[Applause]
no but you know I don't mean to say that
she was bad by feeding us but when
things were rough right afterwards here
have some soup comfort yeah yeah yeah I
miss her I love her and she she really
has made this character come to life I'm
so happy she has a starring role on TV
yeah and playing a man playing a woman
has anybody given you any [ __ ] for
taking a job from a woman
cuz no that goes on all the time now
until you said die I really have never
thought of it because I am I know when I
start trouble well I don't mind I know I
just think that I agree I understand
that thing but this is a comedy right
we're not trying you know we're trying
to make my comedy I would if I was just
a guy that would be terrible please try
to explain logic to thee yeah yeah
rarity police they just want to be yes
it's true they just they want to be mad
they want that woman that's not funny so
she can't have it the woman Brett's
gonna play Zach wanted a woman he had
her picked up Brenda it was a British
actress I never can remember it never I
should call him fake her but she was
busy and she couldn't do the part and
then Zach said I have an idea of a voice
and he said the voice and somebody said
it sounds like Louie Anderson yeah Zach
went like that and he went call him and
they called me and that's really how I
got the part
screwed you Judi Dench
so I read that you cry every day yeah I
tell me about that cuz I am NOT a cry
you know when I cry at movies yes it's
so easy to get me to cry at a movie and
so hard in life what does it say about
me let's talk about that would say about
you is that you're extremely vulnerable
I mean that your two movies know that
you're a vulnerable person and crime
would leave you because you're you know
you would be wide open on that front and
that could be where maybe that's what
but how do you how do you get yourself
to cry every day
um do you just think of something sad no
I'll be talking you know like on the
book tour I've talked about my brother
who was no longer with us okay and you
know I just I miss a miss sad and also
you know we talk about everything that's
going on in it right now the girl who
shot up the YouTube thing right you know
we used you know I'm mental illness in
my family right we used to have
safeguards for mental illness there used
to be hospitals and places and and
checking on in a neighborhood when
things went bad we knew the police we
were connected we have stopped being
connected as human that's so true we are
not connected and if my if our neighbors
were doing something across the street
right my dad well what that honestly
what are you doing over there
and he would call from Interpol with a
wager over here but you can't have a
hundred guns in here you want a little
you want your mom going well I'll call
Shirley cuz she knows right exactly then
she'll well we were connected there was
a there was a book once called it takes
a village yes and that's what that was
about
yes and of course there's a wonderful
book it was that the right-wing hated
yes because it was socialism you know I
really it was just neighbors helping
neighbors and it really is and you know
all of us if right now something
happened
all of us would band together to help
each other so why do we need to wait
until something happens well or we Bend
together and eat each other I mean you
don't you don't know I mean you know
we'd be good they kill first